problem 94.
in jefferson school
300 students study french or spanish or
both
okay they have to do one of those two if
a hundred of these students do not study
french so this sounds like a
venn diagram
let's see
let me draw so let's say that's french
i'll do spanish in a different color
let's say that is
spanish
and we have 300 students and they study
either french or spanish
if 100 of these students do not study
french so what did i say this was french
and this is spanish so 100 of these
students do not study french so this
area right here
is a hundred
right those are people who study spanish
but no french at all
how many of these students study both
french and spanish so that what they
want to know is the intersection of
who studies french and spanish so that's
this blue area right here
so statement number one
tells us of the 300 students
60 do not study spanish
so of the 360 do not study spanish so
essentially
this area right here let me see if i
could
so people who study french but know
spanish
and not i didn't mean they know spanish
people who study french and do not study
spanish that's this right here and
that's 60.
right and let's see if we can use this
information to figure out what the
intersection is
so if you think about it
what we want to do is
the whole universe
so the whole universe is going to be
equal to
the people who study so this 60 people
this 60 people
right
plus
we'll call that the intersection or we
could call that french and spanish
right plus this blue area plus this tan
area
right that's the whole universe and that
is equal to 300.
so people who study french and spanish
plus 160 is equal to 300
divide subtract 160 from both sides
and you get
the people who study just french and
spanish that's what that's 240
that's
140 people study both french and spanish
so statement 1 is sufficient
let's see what statement two gets us
statement two tells us a total of two
hundred forty of the students study
spanish
so statement two we don't know this but
we know that a total of 240 students
study spanish right
so we know that this whole circle is 240
and if we're just trying to figure out
this blue part we just have to subtract
out the tan part
so if we want to know the french chance
fairness french and spanish is going to
be equal to
the whole amount that study spanish
which they just told us 240
minus just the people who study only
spanish right because you can study
spanish and french
so 240 people who study spanish minus
the people who just study spanish so
that's 100 that's that 10 area that also
equals 140. so both statements
individually are sufficient to answer
this question so the answer is d